so kristen you and i are here at the
camp film festival you were here in 2012
for on the road and now you're back
are you nervous or excited what does can
mean to you
um
this is my favorite film festival it
just even you know sitting here doing
junket type interviews it never feels
like you're selling the film it just
feels like um a huge celebration of
cinema and the history of it and how we
fold into that and it's just like it's
never not
it's never not novel it never feels like
you're like oh i guess i'll go talk
about this movies like you know just
yeah i love this place it's such a pure
place
so i watched this film and the first 10
minutes are really difficult to watch as
a mother and you go on this ride with
cronerberg in your own words what are
the vision or the storyline that he
wants to create in terms of a
conversation for the audience i think
it's such a testament to sort of
everything that he's done up to this
point
i find this movie to be shockingly
personal and intimate and and even
though it's a little confronting and at
times absolutely grotesque which
cronenberg fans will appreciate um
there's a sweetness and a tenderness to
it that that um i think is what the
movie actually is about i think there's
a hopefulness even though it is said and
it's in a time a sort of projected
time that seems like a kind of last
gasp of humanity
um that technology really has sort of
created um
a terrain where the body is obsolete and
we are kind of rendering ourselves
useless and and numb but at the same
time art saves always if if there's a
way to touch each other we we will
figure it out you know and so the whole
idea that surgery is the new sex or that
we have to slice each other open to feel
something
it's beautiful and also like what it
takes to create art and how much that
hurts
it holds hands with pleasure
and like however much joy you can feel
probably means that you're someone who
can experience immense pain
and that is okay and if you find others
that you can do it with it's like that's
what we are that's what that's what
humans are and so it's like
i think this movie is actually oddly
like sweet and beautiful even though
it's bloody and crazy
yeah that's what i want to hear your
version of it and describing it that's a
beautiful way to describe it has dylan
seen the film yeah
and are you good with blood i mean from
vampire to this
fake blood doesn't bother me but i think
in real life when i think anything goes
down i'm not
like i don't think i'm great in a crisis
no
yeah but movies don't really disturb me
that much i always have i think i've
been doing them for too long i'm like oh
how did they do that wait oh that's that
kind of blood yeah
crimes of the future what are the crimes
of the present
wow that is a nice closing question
oh man um
without becoming completely
like
clickbait just that it's not a we don't
have long enough to talk about that i
um you know
i think the current um
i think the really obvious crime is
is exceptionally current and happening
right now and hopefully that i mean i
mean we're just i
especially we're making a movie about
bodies and having control over your own
bodies like i i i can't put words to
this because i'd rather just start
screaming and i think it'd be the wrong
format to do that in
um so yeah probably
that and i think i've made myself clear
i just don't know how to say it
perfectly i just think that where we're
at is i couldn't i couldn't be more
terrified at that moment
okay fine i'll leave you with this when
is your wedding day
oh um
yeah uh i don't know i have no idea
we're just like so busy making movies
and you know what i mean like she um she
and i are gonna make a movie together
uh we want to do that first
um we got we're like getting wedding
rings we're just behind we're just like
way behind yeah
i know i never thought i was like a long
engagement person either i was like if
you do it you do it i'm like now it's
just been ages you know i love you and i
love you in this film and i'm so happy
and congratulations and canadian man
cronenberg i know
i know national treasure man thank you
so much thank you
you